English's nightmare in prison began with
his crime one involving his own child I
had a beautiful baby boy three months
old I was going around making phone
calls and I was waiting for somebody to
call him back and I was playing with my
son and I accidentally dropped him
and when I did he landed on the back of
his head um we had hardwood floors in
the house so he fractured his skull in
the back when he landed and he went into
a seizure when the police arrived they
saw a very different story English
already had two warrants for battery on
his record and the evidence suggested
that English had shaken and beaten his
son they arrested me for aggravated
battery cruelty to children and then
when they pulled the plug on my son's
life they upgraded the charges to malice
murder cruelty and children aggravated
assault aggravated battery and an they
stuck on three more counts of felony
murder with each of those charges facing
the possibility of a capital murder
trial he took a plea and is serving a
20-year sentence but in prison crimes
against children are the most despised
even though I didn't do those things
that they said I did you know it's still
a crime involving a child and then you
got a lot of people around here who just
don't like things like that you know
I've had people call me free pick
hypocrite sissy child killer one guy
calls me the professor another guy calls
me XP which is short for Christmas
package
the name seemed like something out of
high school but in prison each one is a
label a brand that opened English up for
the worst kind of attacks it began
simply over a CD player it was involving
gangsters gangbangers you know person
was supposed to be a you know og crib
and I had something he wanted
there was a CD player I had and he saw
the CD player and he used to come and
listen to it all the time the CD player
was stolen and when the gang member got
put in the hole
Adrian English acquired another
dangerous label and so all of a sudden
you know I've got my name being dragged
through the mud people thinking I'm a
snitch and that is the worst label to
have in prison you will get killed for
being a snitch I've seen it happen
English wasn't killed but he says
something else happened something he
refers to simply as it so they moved me
to the cell of another inmate and he
knew what was going on push came to
shove worse came to worse I fought and I
fought and you know there's only so much
fighting you got to do you know but in
the end it wasn't enough and you know
the man knocked me out and when I came
to you know
it was pretty much over and done with
you know the first 24 hours are always
the worst you know cuz you're you're a
shock you're not you think about what
happened why it happened you try to
justify it you try to rationalize it you
blame yourself you think that there's
something wrong with yourself you know
they always talk about it happening to
women out there they don't really like
talking about it happened in the men
because you know we're supposed to be
macho you know we have a line that just
can't be crossed and that line was
crossed with me you know
rape is the secret in prison fuel talk
about and although the prison launched
an investigation there was not enough
evidence to support the charges
in some ways it's made me bitter some
ways has made me more cynical in some
ways it's made me angrier
it's definitely wounded and scarred me
whether it happened or not
adrian english put himself in a kind of
psychological isolation he hopes this
retreat will keep him out of harm's way
at Hayes but in prison there is no
escape
[Music]